i have some interesting information on
how much alcohol you would have to drink
before you develop
liver damage now in high school i drank
some alcohol in college
and then even after college i continued
to drink and experience many of those
what we call hangovers
and i even remember in my late 20s
they had these
i don't know what they were called but
they're like little 7-eleven stores
around town
and you can buy a margarita to go
and so of course i would get myself and
karen a margarita
drive home after work and then get in
this routine of drinking at least one or
two of those each night for about six
months
that probably was the thing that pushed
me over the edge because you're
combining alcohol with sugar and i
noticed my back was very stiff my hands
were arthritic i had complete fatigue i
had bloodshot eyes and of course i was
doing what i thought
was healthy the time which now i know
was not very healthy but i had a very
low awareness of health at the time in
fact
i had zero attention on creating a
healthy body
but of course i was able to get away
with it for so many years until
eventually it caught up with me but
here's the data in alcohol in one study
just 21 binge sessions
produced early stage liver disease
now when i'm talking about binge
drinking sessions i'm talking about more
than five drinks within a two hour
period and when i'm talking about a
drink
uh let me define a drink
that is point six ounces of pure alcohol
which would be equivalent to a can of
beer
eight ounce malt liquor
or a five ounce wine or a 1.5 ounce shot
of liquor so if you did five of those
21 times in a row that could potentially
push you right into an early stage liver
disease and he also found that just one
session of binge drinking
increases your liver enzymes now what
happens when you drink
is that about 25 percent of the alcohol
gets absorbed in your stomach into the
bloodstream and then the rest gets
absorbed in your small intestine now as
it goes through the bloodstream
it goes through your liver and your
liver now is going to break it down and
deal with this toxic material and in
this process of the stages of breakdown
of alcohol
the first stage is pretty toxic to your
liver cells that's where you're going to
get inflammation and eventually you're
going to be getting scar tissue that's
called cirrhosis but on average when you
drink just one drink
it takes about an hour with all the
different enzymes in your liver to break
it down into a
less toxic material but what happens
over time when you continue to do this
is you start to lose the enzyme network
that breaks down this toxic material and
then the toxic material builds up and it
creates a lot of damage within your
liver your pancreas etc what initially
happens first is that you start
developing fat in your liver and then
that fat can create inflammation which
can then lead to scar tissue and also
the fat can create insulin resistance
which can now increase inflammation so
it's kind of a never ending cycle now as
far as inflammation in the liver okay
it's called hepatitis that usually
starts within five years of heavy
drinking on a regular basis
now as far as cirrhosis or scar tissue
that usually takes between five to ten
or more years because if we keep that
liver in a constant state of
inflammation the body is going to start
healing with scar tissue because we also
now have the immune system involved but
what's interesting is that this whole
period of time
you don't have many symptoms you might
have some fatigue
you might look down and see your belly
but not necessarily all the time because
you also can have skinny fat words
throughout the organs but definitely if
your belly is sticking out that usually
means that your liver is fatty now there
also is a condition called ascites which
is not necessarily fat but it's a
protruded belly because your liver is so
bad it's leaking fluid into a sac around
your stomach so that situation is a
fluid-filled sac in your gut because
your liver is very very sick that's a
very advanced stage of liver disease
and then as things progress then you
start developing more and more symptoms
arthritis would be one
itching through the body especially in
the bottom of your feet
you may have jaundice yellowness around
your eyes or your skin
you may have a spike in estrogen and a
lowering of your testosterone
and start developing man boobs things
like that but you're definitely going to
feel lethargic kind of tired you might
have bad breath a loss of muscle but
other than that you'll be perfectly fine
now there's some other variables that
affect how alcohol affects your liver
number one the concentration of alcohol
that you're drinking so you have diluted
drinks or you have more concentrated or
stronger alcohol so we have the
concentration if it's carbonated or not
apparently carbonation increases
the
negative effect on your liver then you
have if you're consuming any food with
that alcohol the food buffers the
negative effect of alcohol on your liver
but what happens is you have a
tremendous amount of oxidation in the
liver and you're getting a lot of free
radical damage and the ability to
counter that with all these enzymes
becomes less and less and less then we
lose the liver function and now we can't
detoxify and now we can't digest like we
should and there's dna damage and even
risk of liver cancer but people with
cirrhosis used to be diagnosed
maybe in their 40s or 50s or 60s but
nowadays it's younger and younger 25
year olds are now being diagnosed with
cirrhosis
in fact between 1999 and 2016
the deaths from cirrhosis have increased
by 65 percent so more and more younger
people are are drinking and experiencing
the negative effects from that now
there's a couple other things that you
need to know about liver damage
consuming sugar okay has roughly about
the same effect as consuming alcohol
especially if you're drinking fructose
as in high fructose corn syrup so just
because someone's not drinking alcohol
doesn't mean they can end up with
any type of problem with the liver
and that is called non-alcoholic liver
disease also
a lot of the medications that people
take also cause a lot of liver damage
so i would say number one alcohol
sugar medications are the top three
things that can destroy the liver as
well as viruses
so if you decide to drink a lot and
become alcoholic it's very very
important to eat healthy at the same
time
to minimize the damage that's going to
occur on your liver and i'm being a
little funny here because usually if
someone is drinking a lot of alcohol
they're probably on a high sugar diet at
the same time now the good news about
the liver
is that it is the only organ
that can completely 100 regenerate
if you stop doing the things that are
causing the destruction
in fact if you have a fatty liver you
can remove 50 of that fat from the liver
just within two weeks
of
avoiding those things that cause the fat
however there's going to be a point of
no return where you've developed so much
scar tissue that
it's going to be irreversible so
hopefully you're not in that situation
yet but if you want to know how to
reverse the liver damage and turn things
around
this is the video you need to watch next